tras la escalada de violencia en Perú la
presidenta Dina boluarte ofrece
disculpas por la cerca de 50 muertes en
las protestas que sacuden al país tras
la salida de Pedro Castillo a principios
de diciembre después de que intentara
cerrar el parlamento no puedo dejar de
reiterar
ni pesar por las muertes de peruanas y
peruanos en los actos de protesta tanto
de nuestros compatriotas civiles como
del valeroso policía que perdió la vida
de manera infausta pido perdón por esta
situación y por lo que no se haya dejado
de hacer para evitar estos
acontecimientos trágicos ha sido
criticada por la represión violenta de
las manifestaciones por parte de las
autoridades al unísono los manifestantes
exigen su renuncia en la noche de este
viernes continuaron los bloqueos al sur
del país donde se han registrado los
enfrentamientos más fuertes el más
reciente ejemplo en la joya Arequipa lo
que queremos es de que se haga una nueva
constitución
queremos que la señora Gina Baluarte se
retire del Congreso no no nos representa
al pueblo no nos representan ahora sobre
la sobre lo que estamos haciendo nuestra
protesta vamos a seguir permanentes no
nos vamos a cansar hasta que no nos
escuche porque el pueblo tiene que ser
escuchado ya estamos en este momento en
este momento estamos en el pie de lucha
todas las regiones del país el querido
Perú estamos en esta lucha por motivo de
aquí la que se vaya la señora Usurpadora
Por qué Usurpadora Pese a que le dieron
al presidente Castillo es es irregular
no no está no está constitucional la
fiscalía general de Perú inició 11
investigaciones para identificar a los
responsables de las muertes en las
protestas la Comisión Interamericana de
Derechos Humanos de visita oficial en
Perú pidió un diálogo amplio y dijo que
la confianza de los peruanos en las
instituciones se ha visto debilitada por
las recientes semanas de agitación
política y social marcado por el peor
brote de violencia en 20 años